karim expats l'idée c'est vraiment de
recréer du lien entre les antillais et
les guyanais qui sont dans nos
territoires et ceux qui sont partis à
l'étranger ou en france hexagonale enfin
dans le monde voilà et et pourquoi parce
que finalement on se rend compte que
l'on n'est pas forcément uniquement
attirés par la france hexagonale mais il
ya beaucoup d'opportunités à saisir
ailleurs et c'est simplement pour
montrer à chacun que l'infini le
caractère infini de ses possibilités en
expliquant finalement le parcours des
autres et qui peut servir de modèle pour
ceux qui aimeraient partir à l'étranger
et aussi pour ceux qui aimeraient
rentrer et qui envisagent de créer leur
entreprise ou même de développer des
échanges internationaux ça fonctionne
vraiment vraiment par le bouche à
oreille c'est une activité que j'ai
commencé en 2013
mais en fait de 2013 à 2017 enfin 2016
je continuer d'animer le blog à côté de
mon travail à temps plein donc c'était
surtout le week-end et sur mon temps
libre
et aujourd'hui depuis huit mois
je suis je me consacre exclusivement à
ce projet que j'ai moins développés
parce que je vois qu'il est vraiment
utile à beaucoup de personnes
les étudiants qui veulent partir les
entreprises qui veulent recruter pour
des personnes qui veulent revenir aux
antilles en guyane les entreprises qui
veulent s'implanter à l'étranger et qui
justement trouve à travers ce réseau
solidaire des personnes qui ont cette
double culture de chez nous qui savent
qu'elles sont soit avoir faire et qui
ont aussi la culture du pays d'accueil
donc c'est assez intéressant comme
profil pour ces entreprises et puis des
partenaires de la mobilité
internationale les les ressources
humaines et le voyage le tourisme enfin
tout un ça ça ça fédère on va dire une
sorte d'écosystème
donc aujourd'hui on retrouve à peu près
mille trois cents personnes inscrites
donc en fait vous allez sur le site il y
à une caraïbes expats maps ou vous avez
un formulaire vous leur enseigner avec
quelques données rapides et ensuite il
ya un système de géolocalisation
automatique qui vous place dans la ville
où vous vivez donc après vous pouvez
zoomer voir les autres personnes qui
sont autour de vous et les contacts et à
accéder à des conseils sur le voyage sur
d'autres thématiques des conseils
pratiques aussi lorsque vous arrivez
dans une ville ego connaissez absolument
rien ni personne
nous organisons justement des événements
donc en martinique en guadeloupe et à
paris pour permettre à cette communauté
qui n'est pas que virtuelle de se
rencontrer aussi physiquement et je suis
moi même intervenant
evènement le prochain aura lieu le 30
mars à partir de 18h30
c'est comme les dj stoxx donc c'est à
l'hôtel batelière et il y aura linkedin
en martinique et l' agence de
communication comme play pour parler de
la rh 2.0
la migration retour et le personal
branding